judge a man by his questions rather than
by his answers
stupid is the man who always Remains the
Same
[Music]
a wise man predicts the future with the
past learn to predict the future with
the wise quotes of Voltaire we have
compiled for you in this video
to not make a man bored
a woman should give him more freedom
the less control a man has
the more faithful he will be to you
all the honors of this world are not
worth One Good Friend
the first sign of love for men is
timidity
in women it is courage
a person is worth something only when he
has his own point of view
War turns into wild beasts people born
to live as brothers
an explained joke
is no longer a joke
tears are silent speech
life is a shipwreck
but we must not forget to sing in the
lifeboats
knowing many languages means having many
keys to one lock
those who can make you believe
absurdities
can make you commit atrocities
the living should be treated with
kindness
but only the truth should be spoken
about the Dead
freedom is not something you have been
given
this is something that cannot be taken
away from you
every man is guilty of all the good he
did not do
it's dangerous to be right when the
government is wrong
the comfort of the rich depends upon an
abundant supply of the poor
ignorance is the greatest disease of
mankind
foreign
cherish those who seek the truth
but beware of those who find it
to give out someone else's secret is
betrayal
to give out yours
is stupidity
may God defend me from my friends
I can defend myself from my enemies
great things require into fatigueable
perseverance
love truth
but pardon error
the name of a person who has done great
things inspires more respect than all
adjectives
God is a comedian playing to an audience
that is too afraid to laugh
the further the Mind marches forward
the more fanaticism gnashes its teeth
dare to think for yourself
in order to know God
you have to be him yourself
the most important decision you make is
to be in a good mood
doubt is an uncomfortable condition
but certainty is a ridiculous one
I would rather obey a fine lion much
stronger than myself
than 200 Rats of my own species
when the mob begins to reason
everything is lost
it is better to risk saving a guilty
person than to condemn an innocent one
think for yourself and let others enjoy
the privilege of doing so too
Faith consists in believing what reason
cannot
people never feel remorse for doing
things that have become their habit
prejudices are what fools use for reason
foreign
we are always in the expectation of
living
would be wise instead of being angry at
the world around us to find the courage
to act
don't think money does everything
or you are going to end up doing
everything for money
marriage is the only dangerous Adventure
available even to cowards
the art of medicine consists of amusing
the patient while nature cures the
disease
perfect is the enemy of good
infinitely small people have infinitely
great pride
the longer we dwell on our misfortunes
the greater is their power to harm us
it is with books as with men
a very small number play a great part
history never repeats itself
man always does
behind every successful man stands a
surprised mother-in-law
to succeed in the world it is not enough
to be stupid
one must also be polite
if a lady says no
it means Maybe
if she says maybe
it means yes
if she says yes
it's not a lady
one great use of words is to hide our
thoughts
it is hard to free fools from the chains
they Revere
when you read authors who write well you
get used to speaking well
how many stupid things people say just
out of a desire to say something
the strength of a woman lies in the
weaknesses of men
a person must dream in order to see the
meaning of life
foreign these quotes from Voltaire show
how one man can write prolifically and
talk about different topics the freedom
of speech and relationships with people
his quotes are soaked with wisdom and
true knowledge thanks for watching